the first certified p4 containment
facility in the united states for
recombinant dna research a laboratory
designed to meet the requirements set
forth in the nih guidelines governing
recombinant dna research is now
available to scientists
the laboratory itself is under negative
air pressure
the experiments are carried out from
beginning to end inside an elaborate
system of enclosed gas tight cabinets
this means that nothing not even the
tiniest particle of dust or air or the
smallest micro organism can penetrate
the heavy stainless steel and glass
cabinets
this system of cabinets measures about
70 feet in combined length it is
contained inside a room which has an
area of about 400 square feet
using the shoulder length rubber gloves
which are tightly attached to the sides
of the cabinets laboratory workers are
able to move and control all the
materials and tools used in the
experiment without direct contact
between their hands and anything inside
the cabinet
each experiment must be carefully
planned well in advance since all of the
materials used in the experiment
including chemicals cultures and
laboratory equipment must be brought
into the group of interconnected
cabinets or cabinet line as it is called
one of the methods of bringing materials
into the cabinet is through an autoclave
or steam sterilizer
equipment and materials are loaded onto
a shelf inside the autoclave for
transfer to the interior of the cabinet
line
a heavy door is then swung into place
and locked to provide a tight seal
a laboratory worker removes them from
the cabinet side of the autoclave
because the interior of the device has
now been exposed to the inside of the
cabinet it will be necessary to run the
autoclave through a sterilizing cycle
before it is opened again on its outside
end
the 250 degree fahrenheit steam pressure
cycle takes time
all large items have to enter through
the autoclave so planning its maximum
use is essential
the cabinet lines are modular that is
made up of individual connected units
allowing the free movement of materials
within the line
at least two workers are required for
most manipulations and movements of
materials a variety of equipment for
experiments must be contained within the
cabinets and that includes a
refrigerator which is used for both long
and short-term storage of materials
here supplies of growth media are being
checked and readied for later use in
preparing bacterial culture
another design feature of the
refrigerator is movable shelves which
slide in and out to allow the laboratory
worker easier access to materials stored
within
note the tools used to extend the
limited reach of the researcher as he
works within the restricted space of the
gas tight cabinets
the cabinet system in this laboratory
has two levels which are connected by a
small elevator or dumb waiter
specially weakened strains of bacteria
which cannot survive outside the
carefully controlled laboratory
conditions are grown in a water bath
located on the second tier of the system
once the cultures have been grown and
are ready for use in the experiment they
are transferred to the nearby elevator
which descends with them to the lower
level
here most of the biochemical and
microbiological steps in the experiment
are actually carried out
the weakened strains of bacteria which
are used in recombinant dna research
make up a second form of containment
called biological containment
although physical barriers or physical
containment are highly effective in
preventing the escape of microorganisms
biological containment adds a built-in
safeguard
the crippled bacteria are so weak that
they self-destruct outside the
laboratory
these two types of barriers physical and
biological are always used in
combination
this particular cabinet system has an
area with glove ports on both sides
this arrangement allows two laboratory
workers to team up for some of the more
delicate operations such as the transfer
of cultures or reagents from one
container to another
continuing the inventory of research
tools mounted within the cabinet line is
a high-speed centrifuge this device
mounted flush with the bottom space of
the cabinet is used in purifying dna
spinning rapidly dna separates from
protein and solvent
the control panel for this centrifuge is
mounted outside the barrier of the gas
tight cabinets
bacteria for experiments such as this
are grown in single colonies which are
cultivated in standard laboratory petri
dishes
the petri dishes are kept in an
incubator inside the cabinet line
the microscope is a vital tool in
experiments involving
microorganisms an instrument is mounted
in this laboratory's line
despite the restraints that are imposed
by the heavy rubber gloves skilled
laboratory workers are able to make
delicate adjustments on the microscope
a closed circuit television system with
the screen mounted just above the
researcher's head provides the means for
viewing
a second means of entering the enclosed
cabinet line is through a device called
a dunk tank
this consists of a tank filled with a
strong liquid disinfectant and is an
integral part of the barrier and like
the autoclave prevents the passage of
unwanted living organism in either
direction
a leak-proof container is used to convey
materials needed inside the line safely
through the dunk tank
note how the attached gloves are pulled
back inside the cabinet
this is due to the negative air pressure
that is constantly maintained within the
cabinets
this added safety feature ensures that
no organism escapes should the gloves be
punctured
although use of experimental animals is
not a significant part of most
recombinant dna research
this laboratory is equipped to house
animals on two tiers within the cabinets
experimental mice like these can be
inoculated and examined within the
cabinets
the daily care and feeding of the
animals is also carried out entirely
within the cabinet system
materials needed to work with and care
for the animals are introduced through
the dunk tank
when necessary cages and waste are
removed in the same fashion that all
other material is taken out through an
autoclave
the material is placed inside and is
then heated to a temperature sufficient
to kill all organisms
at the end of a sterilization cycle
material is removed from the autoclave
for further processing either washing if
it is reusable laboratory equipment or
disposal as trash if it is not reusable
as any material leaves the building it
is sterilized a second time
material is loaded into the autoclave
and again heated to achieve complete
sterilization
we have seen the facilities equipment
and techniques that will be used in this
laboratory
now let's take a close look at the
substance which is the focus of the
scientific activity which will be
carried out here
in order to show more clearly some of
the methods of dna research we are going
through a non-recombinant dna procedure
close-up pictures which you will see of
a bacterial dna culture were made under
p3 conditions
reagents are added to the purified dna
to separate it from other materials such
as protein and to prepare it for
spinning
a glass rod can then be used to spin the
purified dna into a cohesive mass
pressed against the side of the test
tube to eliminate excess moisture the
long strands of dna take on the
appearance of transparent thread wrapped
around the end of the glass rod
the dna molecules may be dissolved again
in a salt solution
for further study and analysis of the
dna's genetic or biochemical makeup if
so desired
at this stage the dna is ready for
spinning or other processing as may be
called for in the experiment